madame nota merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation ce soir le président de
la république n'est pas en odeur de
sainteté auprès de monsieur blondel vous
non plus que pensez vous de l'attitude
actuelle le monsieur blondel dans cette
crise je n'ai pas en juger mais en
l'occurrence pour ce qui est de la
rencontre avec le président république
que j'ai eu aussi la différence entre
marc blondel et moi et peut-être que je
n'attendais pas de confidence jacques
chirac jacques chirac m'a demandé quels
étaient mes positions les positions de
la cfdt sur la réforme de la sécurité
sociale je lui aussi beaucoup disent que
je ne souhaitais pas voir dans cette
réforme et il m'a dit clairement à la
sortie madame je vous ai bien écouté
mais vous savez bien que les arbitrages
appartiennent au gouvernement
bien sûr monsieur baisse d'1 marque pour
bell lorsqu'il s'en prend à vous accuse
finalement d'être d'accord avec le
gouvernement sur la réforme de la
sécurité sociale
en schématisant peuple oui bien
évidemment l'après le gouvernement sur
l'assurance maladie
j'entends bien repris des positions et
des revendications que nous avons à la
cfdt depuis plusieurs mois et plusieurs
années alors évidemment je ne vais pas
au syndicalisme que vous prenez par
rapport à la cgt à l'évidence la sphère
de la sécurité sociale le démontre mais
ça fait déjà longtemps que nous avons le
sentiment qu'il faut aujourd'hui un
syndicalisme qui soient de plus en plus
utile et efficace un syndicalisme qui
fonctionne différemment quand on a 5
millions d'exclus 3 millions de francs
sont à cinq cent mille chômeurs donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
envie d'être un syndicat un
contre-pouvoir libre autonome mais
efficace et obtenant des résultats vient
d'entendre
monsieur bergougnoux président sncf on a
vu que la situation était bloquée à la
sncf on a une semaine qui s'annonce avec
de nouvelles manifestations comment
voyez vous les choses s'opérer écouter à
la sncf je dirais que c'est là une
démonstration de plusieurs années de
manque de courage tente de l'état que du
président certains présidents de la sncf
aussi c'est à dire qu'ils ont toujours
repousser plus loin des décisions qui
devaient être on est au pied du mur donc
plus c'est douloureux des plus a réagi
je suis d'accord avec vous seulement je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est une mode
tout dépend services de quoi il à fond
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les cheminots
sont en droit de demander au
gouvernement qu'est ce que vous voulez
pour la sncf demain votre contrat de
plan vous voulez faire bouger la sncf
peut-être mais pour en faire quoi donc
comprendre qu'il faut bouger
ensuite ils sont en droit de leur
demander qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
pour assurer les complémentarités
nécessaire entre le rail et la route par
exemple et ils sont évidemment en droit
de leur demander à quelle sauce les
salariés vont être en ce qui concerne
assez curieuse social vous pensez que
s'est terminée la réforme va passer de
gouvernement peut tenir sur cette
position
un million c'est le mans je pense
qu'elle peut jeudi qu'elle doit passer
concernant l'assurance maladie et nous
ne serons pas du côté l est de la cfdt
de ceux qui veulent la faire échouer
mais nous avons un gouvernement à l'oeil
la vigilance s'impose car maintenant il
faut appliquer les orientations et ses
lacs le gouvernement va être au pied de
leur vie rencontre tous les lobbys
dernière chose nicole notât
vous avez été quelque peu chahuté par
vos propres par certains de vos propres
militants nordistes un mauvais souvenir
ça vous a choqué vous en êtes remise ça
m'a choqué moralement plus que
physiquement car j'étais bien protégé
mais c'est vrai que c'est tout à fait
déplaisant de voir que cela peut arriver
dans le mouvement syndical
ces gens étaient très minoritaires
agressif verbalement et physiquement ça
n'honore pas ceux qu'ils entendent
défendre enfin je veux dire que les mais
j'en profite merci de me donner votre
antenne car je ne pourrais pas répondre
personnellement à tous les messages de
sympathie et de soutien n'ont été dont
j'ai été l'objet ce week-end et il me
vont droit au coeur je vais vous dire
pas seulement parce que ils ont eu le
sentiment que j'avais
a passé un mauvais moment mais parce que
beaucoup se terminer sous le par cette
forme cet encouragement
nicole tient bon sur la sécu tu tiens le
bon bout et on est avec toi merci nico
nota petite rectification ne nous
apporte pas vont pas donner l'antenne
vous avons invités je dis ça pour les
censeurs qui nous regarde de très près
merci de cette erreur de langage à
l'étranger